I test my films all the time with  audiences and I get feedback and say  what do you think of this hope were you  bored here we you know we overstimulated  here was it too funny here you know it  was too sad here and then just finding a  balance to go okay well now let's take  the audience  you know they've been the video they've  had the Deep meaningful moments you know  they've been it's been emotional now we  can slowly pick them up with some  lightness and get into a few jokes here  and then kind of bees them back into  this bit here and there and it's really  like just sort of massaging the audience  through the story and like figuring you  know asking them are you okay now do you  really want to go now okay well let's go  over here and I'll show you this so  that's  essentially how I try and make them  maybe